It was the worst morning ever.
When Carl woke up, he realized that he didn't do his astronomy and chemistry homework.
Also, the forecast called for rain and that would affect baseball practice.
Suddenly, his mother yelled, "Take out the garbage right now!"
When Carl returned from taking the garbage outside, he was all wet.
"What a terrible day!", he said.
He walked to class.
He put his umbrella on the shelf and sat in the third row.
But the teacher asked why Carl's umbrella was on the floor.
He told her not to blame him, but she sent him to the principal out of spite.
Next, he took a geography test.
Despite studying, Carl didn't know the answers.
He started drawing lightly on his paper.
Carl drew a huge dinosaur.
What if it were real?
He saw it in his mind.
Carl's class said he was a genius for having a dinosaur.
It could interfere with math class too!
Soon, Carl's fame spread through school.
He taught his dinosaur to be very gentle and put it on exhibit.
But admission would only be given to those classmates who paid him a fee.
His idea was super.
"It's time to turn in your tests.", the teacher said.
Carl looked at his paper.
As he was dreaming in class, he hadn't finished the test!